bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got jp
here for round two thank you so much for
joining again sir hey palm thanks for
having me
absolutely you've got some uh some
really big news uh that we talked about
last time that is now
live uh with kind of this blockchain
based uh
fundraise that you're doing but before
we get into that let's just quickly talk
about exodus as a reminder for those who
heard the last episode or who didn't
listen what exactly
is exodus and then kind of what's your
role and what's the story there
yeah exodus is the easiest way to manage
a portfolio of cryptocurrency to send
receive
and a lot of people really love the
in-app exchange inside of exodus
and 1.3 million people trust
x's to keep their cryptocurrency safe
uh me personally my background is in
software engineering
it's born and raised in nebraska and we
knew that to build a company in the
future we had to think about things in
kind of an unconventional manner
and with a big motivation for us was
really about building a future
where people could have that control
have that sovereignty
unlike that of an exchange you know some
of the biggest companies in this space
coinbase and binance
they offer a great service to the space
for sure but you're still
trusting another entity to control your
money not your keys not your coins
everybody's heard that and we subscribe
to that wholeheartedly
got it and so this whole like
fascination and obsession with design is
very obvious when you use the product uh
it's beautiful uh both in the way that
the aesthetic look of it
uh but also in the user experience kind
of the minimal friction of
the number of clicks to do certain
things just talk a little bit about
where does that obsession come from
uh and then how did you guys put that
into a product in really an industry
where it doesn't seem to be
uh kind of the the norm or the standard
i'm really fortunate to have met my
co-founder
daniel uh you know i've told the story
before but you know i was i had a
previous wallet and i was pitching it to
people in san francisco
and somebody came up and like jp this
thing looks like a kindergartner
designed it
and i knew that i had to find a partner
that would help build a good looking
product
and i found that in daniel who has
design experiences at disney apple louis
vuitton bmw
and nike to name a few but uh he he knew
uh he went out and found a team that's
actually even better than him
when it comes to design and uh it really
comes
from the fact of thinking of like to
create a company where
the main stream is going to use
cryptocurrency
we've got to make this stuff easy we
gotta think how people feel about this
stuff
right i mean so much is complicated
today
and um it really comes back down to
thinking about how a person feels when
they use our product
absolutely and so the reason why we're
talking today is because you guys have
uh pursued
uh maybe it was not a new way of funding
the company but definitely a different
way than the traditional
let me go to venture capitalists raise
capital from them um
and so one let's just start with like
what's the funding history of the
company been
and then talk me through what you guys
are doing um and kind of what
uh folks that are users of the product
uh or who are interested what access is
doing like what is the opportunity for
them
yes so we're fortunate that we today
are not venture funded at all now we uh
have done
a couple small seed rounds and we've
raised a little over half a million
dollars
originally and that was back in late
2016 early 2017
but that's all the amount of money that
we've raised and over the years we've
talked to venture capitalists and
there's a lot of value added with
venture capitalists for sure
but we saw a future where
stocks could be put on the blockchain
and we saw that that nobody was
actually doing that and so we thought
that this would be a great
opportunity for us to do that and and
that's why we went down this path it's a
path where we can control
our own destiny and we can also empower
people to use a platform where
long term the vision is that they
control the stocks
you could kind of think of it like the
anti-robin hood right everybody knows
what happened with gamestop and robin
hood
and you know that's such a crappy
situation to be in where you feel
stuck and we don't want people to feel
stuck we want to create a future where
if you have your stocks in a platform
like exodus
you could always take those anywhere
else but we've got to start to set the
standards first
and so the whole idea here is
essentially you're tokenizing equity
right you're tokenizing equity of your
business
uh start with regulation right so uh how
is this legal
and what's changed over the last couple
of months or years
that empowers you to do this yes so the
scc
created what's called a regulation a
offering
and that's what we're doing and that was
one of the biggest things that a lot of
companies haven't done before
in the crypto space there have been two
previous companies
younow and block stack that have done
this but they
uh they were just utility tokens that
they went down this regulation a
offering route
nobody yet has actually done uh
equity until now at this point in time
and so we teamed up with
uh securitize to help us out and they
are powering
essentially the cap table and it's
really cool essentially what they have
are our smart contracts
that that we can use and that's what
helps to change the cap table based upon
if you transfer stock from one person to
another person
it automatically changes the cap table
based upon those those smart contracts
but it's all based on smart contracts
and uh
it was a regulation a offering that
allows us to raise up to 75 million
dollars
got it and are you targeting to raise
actual 75 million or something smaller
yeah we're targeting to raise the actual
75 million in fact
this offering just started
on uh thursday night at at 8 pm
and central and to this moment in time
we have raised near 80 percent of that
uh with the people who have already
invested
um i don't know how much of this data
you know but just is it like
one or two big uh whales and kind of
they're taking you know 10 20 million
allocation sizes or is this a bunch of
people with much smaller denominations
there are certainly whales and we will
talk more about that in the future
but what's really exciting about this is
that
90 of the actual investors by count
are all from non-accredited investors so
that's one of the most exciting things
here is that this is a platform
for the the the normal mainstream person
and that's why we see this is the future
interface to what we believe will be the
future of the stock market
yeah i completely agree uh as we start
to see
more and more companies uh tokenize the
equity what's the
impact to the market uh both as the
founder and ceo
or executive of a business uh but also
as uh
an investor um how do you see this kind
of playing out
yeah i think that a lot of companies are
going to start doing this because
they're going to recognize that
you you can have there's actually two
innovations in the regulation front
there's the regulation a
and there's a regulation cf and so the
regulation cf allows
people to raise up to five million
dollars or companies to raise up to five
million dollars
with very little friction and there are
platforms out there today
that are offering this but nobody has
yet bundled this together
with a wallet a platform that already
holds
money and so we see a future where
companies are just going to you know
sign up a few clicks enter in
information and then your offering
can go live to the mainstream public and
you can issue your own
stock and equity directly on the
blockchain and
give people that control yeah what to me
is so fascinating about this is
uh what you're essentially doing is
you're one using existing regulations
uh to give more opportunity to the
average person
uh which i i generally uh believe is a
positive uh
progress and kind of step forward the
second thing you're doing
is uh you are drastically reducing the
cost and inefficiencies
of uh you as a company in terms of
managing your cap table
and and kind of all the transfer
restrictions and roofers and all that
kind of stuff
but three one of the pieces that i think
people don't quite yet understand but a
couple years ago i wrote about at this
point
uh is that we're actually going to make
it a more fair and
safer market right so regulators rather
than having to
kind of retroactively go and build cases
and enforce on people for doing things
that they shouldn't have done
now the code serves as the law you're
going to be able to prevent
somebody who uh maybe shouldn't transfer
from let's say a
accredited investor to a non-accredited
investor the code will actually prevent
you from doing all that type of stuff
and so it just generally makes it much
easier
more efficient and a safer market in the
equity market right
absolutely i mean this should be like a
regulator's
ultimate dream here because it's all on
the blockchain it's all on a transparent
public ledger that at any moment in time
a regulator could pull up and look and
you know it's something as simple as
like say ether scan if we chose to go
down ethereum
the route of ethereum they could just
pull it up and they could go line by
line
and look at all the transfers that have
taken place and then they could go to
the transfer agent and cross-reference
the records and it's all there
it's all public and uh yeah i think this
is an innovation that
will be safer for for both the
mainstream and regulators for sure
absolutely talk to me as much as you can
in terms about how much does this cost
for you guys to go do what was the time
frame how
many people internally were working on
it just like if somebody else says hey
this is sounds like a really interesting
idea maybe i should do it for my company
what are some of the things that you
would tell them in terms of uh
you know just the investment that you
had to make to actually be able to get
in this position
so originally we had this vision that we
were going to do
what we kind of thought of as a world
public offering that anybody in the
world could participate
and buy shares directly in the company
directly on the platform
that was the original vision now we
learned a lot along the way
and so we started this process
it was in may of 2020 is when we started
this process
and we we started learning like okay
there are a lot of laws and regulations
that we have to
adhere to in different jurisdictions and
we still may actually be able to do the
international component but we're
working through that right now
so but we had to suspend that part and
then i learned
there's such a thing as like even blue
sky states that means states like
texas arizona and florida have
additional regulation
in place that you have to do additional
things
and to move fast we had to not we cannot
offer
those three states as well so we learned
that so in retrospect
if we knew all of these things up front
we would have gotten every component in
place to make sure that we could do
all the states and we could do
international out of the gate
and so uh like i said we started this
process in may
we submitted in september and you know
with with
tesla buying bitcoin and um
you know michael saylor buying bitcoin
you know we we found out
end of the year earlier this year like
we gotta really put the pedal to the
metal
and get this done and uh and yeah maybe
there's a little bit of friendly
competition to get this out of the gate
before uh
before coinbase ipo so we were working
our tails off to to get this out of the
gate and
happy to say that that we did it um
but it was a long long process and we've
like i said we've learned a lot and
there's a lot of
things that we could definitely help
other companies with advice
on on actually making this a reality now
to answer your question about
cost this it costs anywhere from a mil
one to two million dollars if you
include marketing
and legal spend it it got it
and so when you start to think through
um
kind of the business in general
obviously you've been able to tokenize
the equity you're going to put that
uh on the blockchain and the cap table
uh any thoughts around like
on-chain cash flows or uh increasing the
transparency around like the business
metrics
which i think is kind of like the holy
grail of a lot of these efforts
absolutely so one of the aspirations
that we have as a company is to become
one of the most
transparent companies in the world so
what that means to us
is that you know now that essentially we
are becoming
sort of like a public company and so
that means we have to put our financial
statements out regularly
and their audited financial statements
in addition to that
i think it's important for us to
actually put out you know more
uh information on in terms of the
business month to month
put out things like a road map put out
financials
and metrics like that so that they're
out there for the public to see at any
moment in time
and uh you know maybe we've even go as
far as
just putting raw bank statements up on
our website and people can see
how much i love like steak and lobster
or things like that right and so
you know what whatever it is things like
that that can really let people know
like hey
this company is very transparent and and
how they
they behave with their their financials
uh
you know this is a company that i want
to you know i want to use their software
to manage my cryptocurrency
absolutely and so when you start to
think through um
kind of the ramifications with these
other businesses what is
going to take like is there an
inflection point uh is it
them seeing you be successful similar to
how microstrategy
uh kind of open the floodgates for
people putting bitcoin in the public
markets on their balance sheet
do you think that uh once exodus is
successful here then all of a sudden
other people will run and go do it or is
there some other infection point that
you're waiting for
uh yeah that's a great question i think
that there's still pieces that need to
be put in place and i'll explain so
if you think back to maybe the late late
70s
and you know as kind of the personal
computer revolution right
in the early days people were going to
these kind of computer clubs and
you'd buy like a motherboard and then
you'd have to find
all the pieces to assemble the actual
computer
you could find your keyboard and the
monitor and all these pieces
nobody yet had really packaged
everything
up in an easy computer until
uh apple and ibm came along and so that
was the big inflection point in the
the you know the pc revolution and for
us what it is is that
okay so we've we're we're doing this
offering
great but we also have to allow people
to actually
trade the assets so that is a big
component as to what's coming and so
what we're doing is we like to think of
the same thing as how i described with
the the pc revolution is
we are packaging up everything in
one software interface so that people
can
do both the offering and then actually
do the secondary market trading
and that part hasn't happened yet but we
believe that
once the secondary market trading
actually happens
that and other companies see like oh wow
exodus has had a lot of success with
this
you know we should consider doing
something like this that's when we think
that
the floodgates will start to open i tend
to think that you're gonna be on the
right side of history here my friend
uh if somebody's interested in learning
more about exodus learning more about
this opportunity where should they go
uh and what will they find there so you
just go to exodus.com
and you can just at the top of the page
you'll see that it says the exodus
public offering
is live and people can click that you'll
see the progress
how about how far we're at and then you
can download exodus and then you can get
started and then at that moment in time
you if you wanted to participate you
would register with uh securitize
directly inside of exodus
and it'll walk you through the process
very straightforward and very simple for
people to do this
yeah what's so fascinating to me about
this and just to kind of summarize for
everyone what's going on here right is
uh jp and the rest of the team they've
built an amazing product uh which has
turned into amazing business
uh and what they're able to do is able
to go to that customer base along with
uh other folks who are not professional
venture capitalist investors and they're
able to say listen
we've got a great business would you
like to participate in the upside of
this
uh and do it within the existing
regulatory framework uh
and do it in a way that is much more
efficient and lower cost for them
in terms of managing that cap table it
provides liquidity opportunities for
uh investors like it's just overall a
much much better system
um and so i think that uh what we're
watching here is not only one pioneering
work by you guys
uh the folks that securitize and others
but more so i think that this just gives
us a glimpse into the future right of
hey why is every company not going to do
this well they probably are going to do
it
and so it ends up just being a matter of
time uh before this goes from kind of a
contrarian idea to a consensus idea
absolutely and pomp i would say that a
lot of companies the reason they're not
doing it today
is because to be fair that this market
is still very early very young
and so if you are a venture-backed
company totally understandable that when
when it
you go public you need to get a return
and you want to go to markets with high
liquidity
and so it makes sense why companies are
you know choosing to list on the nasdaq
and your new york stock exchange
i get it but given that we aren't
venture backed
we have our our cap where our uh
treasury was already you know we already
have quite a bit of money on our
treasury
we could afford to go down this path
with
almost zero downside if if we were wrong
on this and it turns out we're not wrong
on how this is going to play out
so uh and we're going to get the
liquidity going and i think that's when
other companies are going to start to
see like wow this is a huge opportunity
i uh again i think you're on the right
side of history here my friends so it's
uh
super cool to have talked to you before
you launched it it's cool now to kind of
talk to you walla
while it's going and then we'll maybe
have to do one again once everything's
closed up to
talk about how it went uh where can
people find you on the internet if uh if
they want to uh just
follow you or kind of stay close to what
you're doing and thinking
yeah the easiest way is on twitter uh my
handle is jp richardson on twitter so
that that's the easiest way for people
to
follow me awesome uh if i have to
leave you with uh one prediction or
you're gonna leave us with one
prediction
um i'm gonna let you choose do you wanna
talk etf
or uh or coinbase
in terms of so etf happening or
or what so you can either choose to
predict uh do we get an etf in 2021 or
not or you can choose to
uh guess what you think the highest
market cap coinbase hits this year which
one you want to go for
okay um you know i'll i'll go for both
so okay
yes etf in 2021 i think there's no doubt
about that
um and i say that because right now it
seems to me as an outside observer
that other companies are using by
default microstrategies in etf
and so i think given that we're also
seeing etfs in canada
and i think i think there's two in
canada and there's one recently in
brazil
that the the sec i'm just against purely
speculating here
that they're going to have to to approve
an etf so i think
no doubt we see an etf in 2021 and let's
see okay
coinbase market cap highest market cap
in 2021 i'm gonna say they
i'm gonna i'm gonna go 200 billion i'm
gonna go 200 billion
on on that highest not not not on the
non-initial day i don't know again this
is pure oh i think
advice uh pure speculation just a guess
you think higher is that what you're
thinking
you ready so i did this with people when
he asked me what i thought his thing was
going to sell for
i was trading at 3 million i said 50. it
ended up being 69. so i undershot
uh i think that there is a pretty
material chance that coinbase trades up
to half a trillion dollars in 2021 500
500 billion dollars
you know what you you might be right
because a lot of these
institutions are using coinbase to
actually be the custodian of their
bitcoin and crypto
so uh man that's a bold prediction you
might be right on that one
we will see we will see all right my
friend i appreciate the predictions
uh you guys are doing fantastic work
over at exodus uh anyone who wants go
check out exodus.com you can see what
they're doing with tokenizing the equity
uh again i think it's just a glimpse
into the future so even if you're not
interested
uh doing any investing activities you
should just go check it out and kind of
see how everything's structured
and kind of see what uh what people are
doing at the edges of innovation
but i really appreciate you jumping on
uh today and
we will have to do this again in the
future all right perfect thanks pomp